since Spielberg's dinosaur classic
Jurassic Park hit cinemas in 1993 there
have been several sequels of varying
quality let's not mention the talking
Velociraptor the series reboot Jurassic
world released last year was not only a
commercial success but also a hit with
the fans and now a sequel is in the
works i'm simon and hold on to your
butts this is your prehistoric news
update the sequel to 2015 smashing
action movie Jurassic world has found
its director a tweet from the official
Jurassic world Twitter account confirmed
that you an Antonia bianna will direct
us at world to the Spanish director also
held the orphanage and the impossible
Jurassic world director Colin Trevorrow
wrote the script for the sequel
alongside derek connolly and will remain
attached the project of the producer the
film is scheduled to open on June 22nd
2018 as for trevorrose directoral future
he is directing Star Wars Episode nine
deadline reports at the first movie
stars Chris Pratt and Bryce Dallas
Howard are expected to return for the
sequel plot details are being kept under
wraps for now but Trevorrow is hinted
that the concept of dinosaurs chasing
people around on an island might be
somewhat tired at this point Colin
Trevorrow said in a September 2015
interview it will get to be a different
kind of film he then went on to say the
audience has given us permission to a
certain extent to take this to the next
level and I don't necessarily mean in
scale I feel very strongly that it's not
about more dinosaurs or bigger and
better dinosaurs it's about using this
as a starting point for a much larger
story about our relationship with these
animals Jurassic world is now the fourth
most successful movie of all time with a
worldwide gross of over 1.6 billion
dollars it sits behind only Star Wars
The Force awakens Titanic and Avatar do
you think they can go bigger and better
than the indominus rex any ideas for
some new made-up dinosaurs that could
feature in the sequel let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at the Jagan all thanks for
watching and for your entertainment news
keep it GameSpot